vous dites ce jour-là j'ai pris un TGV
dans la gueule quand même je crois que
c'est un peu normal
bonsoir
je voudrais vous montrer quelque chose
[Musique]
c'est lui cette vidéo fait le buzz sur
Internet dans le monde entier depuis
quelques semaines on y découvre un
sans-abri au physique d'Apollon en train
de faire ses exercices de musculation en
pleine rue cet homme Jacques c'est vous
vous raconterez votre histoire à 20h
[Musique]
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes le SDF de la vidéo fait le
buzz sur Internet dans le monde entier
depuis quelques semaines on regarde
[Musique]
alors voilà Jacques vous exprimez pour
la première fois c'est dans SNC je vous
en remercie
alors vous êtes né le 8 avril 1961 Alger
père brigadier-chef dans la police
nationale mère vendeuse dans une
boutique puis femme au foyer en 1962 au
moment de l'indépendance de l'Algérie
votre famille rentre à Paris là vous
êtes un enfant rêveur un peu fleur bleue
passionné par la musique classique par
l'opéra et par Pavarotti
c'est bizarre
en tout cas à l'adolescent ça vous
empêche pas de vous mettre au sport de
combat judo box karaté et musculation en
fait vous faites du sport tout le temps
c'est à dire que Paris avec un pote il
te tiens je vais te faire sans pompe
comment tu paries fait son pont vous
jouez avec des haltères que vous
fabriquez avec des manches à balai enfin
passez votre temps comme ça étant enfant
à faire du sport quoi complètement alors
à 18 ans vous êtes appelés sous les
drapeaux et vous retrouvez en revenant
Florence qui a 15 ans et qui est comme
vous fille de flic et là c'est votre
première grande histoire d'amour
faites un enfant qui s'appelle Rémi qui
née en 1983 et là vous découvrez le
monde du culturisme Arnold
Schwarzenegger évidemment et un film
culte qui s'appelle pumping iron et là
vous dites c'est beau quoi ça vous plaît
tout vous plaît là je suis obligé de
merde c'est quoi ce truc là et bien sûr
ça gonfle ça veut tout dire et voilà
l'histoire s'est éclate alors à l'époque
avec Florence vous faites les saisons
c'est à l'été vous êtes sur la Côte
d'Azur et l'hiver vous êtes à la
montagne jusqu'au jour où vous décidez
de vous poser quelque part et là vous
conduisez la bagnole et Rémi qui est
encore un bébé dit Marseille Marseille
une chanson de Johnny dans voiture mais
d'aventure c'est l'aventure Marseille
vous installez à Marseille alors le
problème Jacques si vous êtes
extrêmement généreux
et à l'époque vous ramenez beaucoup de
SDF à la maison vous leur ouvrez non
seulement la porte de votre foyer mais
aussi la porte du frigidaire et aussi
votre porte-monnaie et là et là est trop
mon cœur ce qui fait que ça faisait
souffrir les gens que je vais aimer à ce
moment-là et la Florence s'en va quand
même elle a raison et là vous commencez
à déconner prenez de la daube un rail de
coq un rail de Braun et voilà après ça
va très vite on croit tout bien faire et
alors Laurence c'est votre deuxième
histoire d'amour elle a du pognon quand
on aime on ne compte pas et là c'est la
grande vie quoi vous payez toute la
daube que vous voulez quoi
je travaille beaucoup je parle beaucoup
de sous et elle est assez aisée mais
entre guillemets c'est une femme
magnifique une grande dame et voilà et
puis ça va très très vite
mais rien lui donner me casser que lui
donner ce que j'ai donné parce que mais
la mort était vrai alors au milieu des
années 90 vous remontez à Paris et là le
retour de bâton est assez violent lors
d'un test de dépistage du sida vous
découvrez que vous êtes malade ça veut
dire que toute votre vie vous allez
vivre avec la trithérapie à partir de là
vous dites ce jour-là j'ai pris un TGV
dans la gueule quand même je crois que
c'est un peu normal ouais donc après
c'est essayer d'être plus fort que la
maladie dans tous les sens du terme
alors à Paris vous faites les marchés
vous achetez des stocks de bijoux que
vous revendez aux Puces de Saint-Ouen
mais vous êtes cassé à l'époque quand
même par la séparation avec Laurence
complètement la consommation de drogues
s'accélère un nombre premier plus de 2-3
g de repos par jour non je suis plus à
l'héroïne synthétique là j'arrive à
Paris et là il y a le craque la coque
vous avez pris du crack à l'époque
[Musique]
une bonne coque elle a très bonne coque
très bonne alors voilà donc vous êtes
défoncé comme un ouf et mais je vais
travailler tous les matins dans des pips
chauds extraordinaire si vous allez rue
Saint-Denis à Pigalle vous baisez sur
des scènes de pipe chaud mais comment
vous arrivez à bander en prenant le
numéro alors là vous avez fait la
demande de la réponse monsieur redisant
les deux périodes où je travaille dans
les pips chauds j'avais arrêté alors là
vous fréquentez la rue la mort c'est que
dans ce milieu de la daube il y a des
matins vous dormez dans la rue vous
réveillez un cadavre à côté de vous et
des portefeuilles ouverts enfin c'est
quand même
mais vous survivez dans dans ce milieu
où les coups de couteau sont sont
faciles
et vous mettez en ordre vous êtes un
loup solitaire et vous avez des sous on
vous respecte on voit pas le
portefeuille juste cette chance purée
que tu arrives avec deux plaques on a
envie de te tuer
et un jour votre fils Rémy se décide à
vous secouer et vous demandez il faut
que tu décroches de la daube papa il a
voulu dites tu as raison je vais arrêter
tout seul et lorsque j'aurai réussi je
reviendrai te voir c'est pas beau ça
et vous le faites c'est ça
je suis dans un appartement quand je dis
à tout le monde j'ai arrêté tout le
monde croit que que j'ai pas arrêté
parce que je changeais là encore plus
défoncé mais vous avez arrêté comment
vous avez pris de la méthadone vous avez
pris quoi si après j'étais chez les
médecins j'ai piétiné j'ai titillé mais
dans l'ensemble la démarche était gagnée
après ça a été des anxios et puis
somnifères vous êtes fort alors pendant
votre rédemption vous prenez contact
avec une association de séropositif à
Montpellier c'est comme ça que vous
rencontrez le troisième grand amour de
votre vie Nathalie et là pendant 10 ans
vous avez parcourir de la France et ben
c'est une grande histoire d'amour elle
aussi barrée que moi elle est belle elle
est intelligente elle est forte elle est
fan du siècle femme libérée un peu
hystérique
moi je suis pas fini ça donne quelque
chose explosif quoi et vous faites quoi
on fait tout on fait la même chose on
boit on danse on fait l'amour on est
libertin
on fait tout alors voilà vous parcourez
la France et puis c'est la rupture on
est allé s'en va vous espérez qu'elle va
revenir mais elle revient pas la raison
ouais
elle revient pas vous installer près de
Montpellier sous une tente dans un petit
bois à côté d'un étang et là ce qui est
extraordinaire si vous continuez à faire
votre muscu tous les matins
jeunes de vie et de la méditation aussi
tout le temps ici de savoir qui vous
êtes et à la sortie de cette réflexion
vous vous dites je suis Jacques je suis
libre et j'aime la vie c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait voilà vous vous trouvez qui
vous êtes vraiment et vous vivez avec ça
c'est ça
tout à fait alors parfois vous remontez
à Paris et là vous vous dormez dans la
rue même quand il fait moins 10 alors on
vous dit comment vous faites il dit je
mets des cartons à l'ancienne c'est ça
je pense que je pratique le
thermodynamique je sais pas si ça se dit
ça fait les gamins intelligent
récupérer la chaleur pas avoir des temps
trop fermés comme des apparts où il y
aurait de la condensation faire mon
sport c'est quand même faire circuler le
sang la maladie du siècle c'est mauvais
circulation du sang et puis le
bodybuilding et du sport à partir voilà
et un regard des gens pas luciné est-ce
que vous faites du bodybuilding dans la
rue vous utilisez le mobilier urbain
c'est les grilles les lampadaires vous
devenez une espèce de personnage assez
populaire les gosses viennent vous voir
et vous touchent les biscotos ils disent
non il est costaud Jacques finalement
vous devenez un professionnel
les championnats de France
plusieurs fois de cultureistes de rue
alors on fait le problème si vous avez
pas vu votre fils Rémi de depuis 10 ans
et là il y a quelques mois un petit film
sur vous dans la rue déclenche un énorme
buzz sur Internet 3 millions de vues en
quelques jours dans le monde entier et
les journalistes de partout vous appelle
des gens de Russie de Pologne du Japon
de Thaïlande d'Espagne même
Schwarzenegger a relayé la vidéo sur sa
page Facebook excusez moi c'est ça me
fait un peu j'hallucine quoi je mais
c'est vrai
et Rémi finit par vous voir évidemment
il finit par tomber sur la vidéo alors
il vous a invité Rémi à passer Noël en
Alsace et en fait vous hésitez parce que
vous vous dites [ __ ] il a des gosses
je vais pas arriver les mains vides
si tu vois pas tes enfants mais un
moment il faut que tu réalises que c'est
une bonne quête ne les vois pas mais
quand tu le il faut que vous soyez en
face pour les petits enfants un père qui
veut dépasser son fils ou un fils il
veut dépasser son père ça donne des
mauvaises synergies alors là je vais le
voir il m'a vu il peut dire papa tu es
un con sur ça ou pas j'ai jamais dit non
à mon fils moi aussi et c'est le bonheur
il a quelque chose à vous dire en fait
et ben tiens ça tombe bien je voulais te
glisser un petit message papa je voulais
dire que franchement waouh quel parcours
ce que tu as accompli c'est juste
démentiel quelle forme physique je suis
juste sidéré de ce que j'ai vu sur cette
vidéo
je voulais aussi te dire que quoi que tu
penses je suis fier de toi qu'on a
qu'une seule vie qu'il faut la croquer à
plein dedans qu'on est pas sage sur
cette terre qu'il faut qu'il faut y
aller à fond quoi donc j'espère
sincèrement qu'on te voit pour Noël en
plus j'ai coupé des grosses bûches de
bois là j'arrive pas à les porter tout
seul j'étais tout petit bras j'ai besoin
de toi pour m'aider à les emmener là
pour allumer un petit feu le soir du
réveillon donc voilà trêve de
plaisanterie on t'attend tous tous je
dis bien sous tes petits enfants ma
femme moi pour passer un super réveillon
à tes côtés donc voilà je t'aime et puis
à très vite ciao bye bye
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez y aller
il se sera content Rémy bravo
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innaharditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu